Thank You moon mr. secretary-general
thank you first of all for this 10 years
a Madame Dupree she don't Bienvenue
shrikant uncle visa vitruvian man have
another polymer young competitive eaters
osservatorio de la commission on Katie
miss Yun gesture que vous con ese know
Luciana the European Union has a long
and proud record of leadership on
climate change globally problem a
problem globally lucemon attero nunzia
party siamo Noi Kelly apart any amo y
abbiamo eldo ver y preserve ARLA editors
metwally I know severely the EU has
nothing to do with this Andy you should
not ratify this climate agreement
you
to situation confident I do I don't a
bad mom at a video la confianza
situation arose a situation olo save you
a la fundación de la democracia musa
Vong said confianza a tamale he per
gallon on pure girth thousand become the
sky fuel distributing the tailor the
Gazelle shaft Hadid are open yummy guns
under a vega in gallatin under gazeta
Alice fredenham alpha papa perhaps the
only difference between this summit and
the others have come before was at this
time you can really blame the UK for the
failure to achieve any kind of agreement
while hospitals schools UN humanitarian
convoys are bombed and starved EU
leadership to come to negotiated peace
is still lacking what we need now is a
red card that is strategic sanctions
against Russia and calling the thing as
it is crime against humanity get cydia
van zeeland does is denzel pool maxvill
and vehicle be in oakland cool mac true
cost of asset swallow it is true that
abortion laws are made by national
governments and national parliaments but
that is not to say that the European
Union has not to say anything one of the
feeling we have here when we have all
these brilliant ma'am pandits talking
about our body is that we share with the
women of poland that we are not
incubators versions in nasha discusses
bested me taba combines fox HED scoot
ova host a Victorian NEMA Eva pavada
chief fascia the doctorate Parliament
Europe a skinny Maghreb Nina today I'm
going to use the speaking time that I
get in this debate in order to make
voices heard that have very often been
overheard and overlooked in the debate
and those are the brave polish activists
who have been fighting in the streets in
the parliament and everywhere in poland
in the last weeks and month we demand
respect for our dignity and bodily
integrity our right to privacy health
and life
protection